sur la croisette dans le secret d'une
suite au sixième étage de ce palace
léa seydoux nous a laissé filmer ce
qu'on ne voit que rarement avec sa
maquilleuse son coiffeur et sa styliste
personnelle l'instar se prépare avant la
montée des marches
le rouge à lèvres rose c'est plus
féminin mais comme ça je trouve que ça
lui donne plus de caractère pour la
jeune femme de 31 ans ce n'est pas le
premier festival de cannes
mais la pression monte
c'est toujours en couple et
d'appréhension personne aucune actrice
toujours un bon pour le tapis rouge elle
a choisi cette robe de grand couturier
très ajustée les la ceinture avec ça te
convient rien n'est trop beau pour
habiller la nouvelle princesse du cinéma
devenue en dix ans l'une de nos grandes
stars internationales une carrière
fulgurante qui a décollé ici même à
cannes il ya trois ans kanu forcément
pour lier un événement qui a marqué à
tout jamais donc venu l'essai pour moi
c'est évidemment ça mais je me
souviendrai toujours du moment j'ai eu
la palme
c'était en 2013
le jury présidé par steven spielberg
rendent alors un verdict exceptionnel
dans l'histoire du festival de cannes
il s'agit
il décerne la palme d'or pour la vida
d'elle à son réalisateur mais aussi aux
premiers rôles du film adèle exarque
kopoul hausse et il est assez doux
jamais un acteur ou une actrice l'avait
à cannes obtient la récompense suprême
qui remercie tous les gens qui ont
participé à ce film
merci le jury merci à del merci grégory
web dans le public
l'un des hommes les plus puissants du
cinéma le milliardaire jérôme seydoux
président des studios pathé le grand
père de léa
la famille seydoux contrôle aussi la
gaumont léa seydoux est donc une
héritière l'enfant d'une dynastie
récemment james bond girl elle a joué
avec les plus grands acteurs tourné avec
les plus grands réalisateurs
cette année xavier dolan pour son film
juste la fin du monde
une ascension irrésistible qui dérange
parfois selon ses détracteurs
cette petite fille bien né devrait avant
tout son succès à son nom elle affirme
au contraire avoir gravi les marches
seul tant bien que mal un cane paris et
au sénégal
nous avons tenté de résoudre le mystère
les uns ses doigts
là
à paris les aviez à l'abri des regards
dans un havre de paix loin de la vie
trépidante d'une star internationale
elle a emménagé récemment dans cette
maison sur deux étages
un petit coin de paradis avec son jardin
et ses oiseaux
je garde tout coeur pour cette liaison
donc voilà h arrivée et puis j'ai vu
jardin et j'ai adoré le jardin j'ai
regardé j'ai tout de suite su que ce
serait ma maison voilà et jamais je
n'aurais pensé que je trouve à une
maison qui me ressemblerait l'otan
c'est la première fois que l'actrice
ouvre ses portes à une caméra de
télévision
son nouvel intérieur un tchèque a fait
elle l'a décoré à son image dans chaque
pièce
le style est rétro classique est branché
à la fois au deuxième étage
le salon est envahie par ses fans donc
ça c'est tout mes lettres auxquelles il
faut que je réponds qu elle reçoit des
courriers du monde entier depuis ses
rôles dans la vie d'adèle et james bond
j'en reçois de chine lassé du japon
encore du japon
ces témoignages de fans
elle aime les lire tranquillement ici
j'ai 15 ans la vie d'adèle m'obsède
je les regardais hier soir et je me
crois capable de le revoir chaque jour
sinon plus je remercie bien sûr
également à del et abdellatif mais vous
et vous seulement pour mon émotion pour
votre mèches bleues merveilleuse pour
votre regard pétillant et profond dans
lequel j'ai envie de nous plonger pour
votre sourire narquois
voici une photo de moi avec l'instrument
qui fait partie de ma vie et qui tout
comme emma et sa peinture me permet de
m'exprimer
ces dizaines de lettres qu'elle reçoit
chaque semaine elle prend la peine d'y
répondre elle même
touchés et un peu stupéfaite de cette
célébrité mondiale
dix ans à peine après ses débuts dans le
cinéma je me projetais pas en visant un
jour j'aurai mon nom de la fiche
j'avais pas conscience vraiment ça
puisque je voulais c'était faire des
films
en fait je crois que j'imaginais pas non
plus le fait d'avoir que ça prenne ça
prenne cette ampleur on sait que j'avais
faire des films et serment a été énorme
cette photo on voit que j'ai des plaques
de timidité célèbre et timide déterminée
et fragile
là y'a quelques photos je conçois pas
mal
léa seydoux est faite de paradoxes
maintenant elle tient à nous montrer que
le début de son existence n'a pas été
aussi heureux que ses origines
familiales le laisse penser
passeport
léa est né dans le chic xvième
arrondissement de paris au sein d'une
famille privilégiée mais elle se
souvient d'une enfance chaotique parfois
douloureuses j'étais déjà mélancolique
regarde comme ça c'est parents sont deux
héritiers fantasque et anticonformiste
son père henri seydoux est une sorte de
géo trouvetou toujours dans les nuages
sa famille et la dynastie la plus
influente du cinéma français
en 1982 il épouse valérie chou berger
qui a déjà trois enfants
artiste bohème elle partage sa vie entre
paris et le sénégal profitant de la
fortune familiale faite dans la
pétrochimie la petite léa grandi dans
une famille recomposée et ses parents
divorcent quand elle a trois ans
je pense que je souffrais de l'absence
de mes parents mais je pense aussi que
j'étais un peu transparente
c'est à dire que j'ai aussi grandi dans
cette famille où il y avait beaucoup de
frères et soeurs ou ma mère était comme
ça un personnage un peu insaisissable et
toujours en partance et que j'étais
s'est livré à moi-même j'ai énormément
de poux et j'avais des poux pas des fous
comme les enfants ont parfois des
poussées que j'ai vraiment des poux je
pense que j'ai passé mon enfance en tir
à avoir des poux j'avais le sentiment
enfants que j'aime exister pour personne
donc c'est ce sentiment d'être
transparents et de pabr la parole en
fête
solitaire peu assidus à l'école
léa devient une ado à problèmes qui
déprime et se cherche
j'ai eu des périodes des looks
adolescente je faisais des uv j'étais
blonde platine je suis passé quand même
à 18 ans elle rate le bac et arrêtent
l'école elle n'a encore jamais foulé les
planches d'un théâtre c'est très très lo
enfin c'est surtout la boîte cadeau
pourtant chez elle trône la palme d'or
remportée dix ans plus tard pour la vida
d'elle ouais je suis fier c'est un
moment fort de de mon existence
ce prix comme je n'ai aucun diplôme
j'ai pas mon brevet d'un combat que pas
rien c'est un peu le seul diplôme que
j'ai si on peut appeler un diplôme alors
comment cet adolescent a perdu et est
devenue l'une des plus grandes stars du
cinéma actuel
après son échec au bac comme n'importe
quel jeune qui rêve de devenir actrice
elle déniche dans les pages jaunes
ce petit théâtre qui propose des
ateliers de cinéma
elle décide de pousser la porte
pour voir j'avais déjà vu
jb c'est jean bernard fait aussi son
premier professeur tu reviens à la
maison
ouais à l'époque il voit débarquer dans
son cours une jeune femme mal dans sa
peau 2005
tu vois cette 2005
léa est rongé par la timidité elle reste
d'abord assise spectatrice du court
j'étais souvent au sur cette estrade ici
j'étais là voilà j'ai rencontré jb c'est
vrai que ça m'a aidé parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a donné confiance en moi
qui m'a regardé qu'a eu un regard très
doux et très attentif et tout d'un coup
je savais je sais pas pourquoi je
sentais que ma place était là c'est à
dire que j'étais sur ceux sur cette
estrade et je regardais les élèves jouer
et ça me fait j'avais envie d'y aller
elle surmonte ses peurs et descend sur
scène un caméscope capte ses premiers
pas et des congrès on a eu des volets
voit voler je vois verizon ils ont
appris
les âges savait qu'il fallait qu'elle
accouche quelque chose elle était dans
le silence
elle était dans l'absence de mot parce
que elle est restée très longtemps dans
la cne et puis d'un seul coup la parole
s'est libérée mais c'était pour jouer
désormais quand elle vient ici ce n'est
plus pour prendre des cours mais pour en
donner en toute décontraction
il élève en bois c est devenue une
actrice expérimentés qui délivre ses
conseils aux jeunes comédiens lors de
master class
par exemple comment apprêter le son
texte avant de jouer une scène je
travaille très différemment fonction
chine que je fais par exemple le film de
kechiche
d'une certaine façon j'ai pas vraiment
travailler puisque je sais que c'était
beaucoup d'improvisation où j'apprenais
l'idée l'idée de la scène il ya des
films sur lesquels j'ai beaucoup
travaillé par exemple évidemment les
films en anglais je travaille parce que
c'est pas ma langue maternelle puis je
travaille l'accent et puis souvent comme
c'est des acteurs je suis un peu
impressionnés quand même merci
si la timidité de la star n'a pas
disparu elle a aujourd'hui appris à
faire avec les deux simples en face de
nous j'ai je jetais s'est parlé entre
nous alors qu'on se sent on se connaît
c'est moi qui trônait ce passage dans le
théâtre de jb a été une révélation
en 2006 après quelques mois de cours
la jeune femme de 20 ans décide de
tenter sa chance dans les castings il
lui faut plusieurs tentatives pour
décrocher son premier rôle dans un film
mes copines ou les vases y décroche le
15 pas de problème
mais surprise le 15 c'est la finalité
finances le film est coproduit par son
grand père jérôme seydoux qui n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions
les a retenus parmi quatre mille
candidate se défend d'avoir bénéficié
d'un traitement de faveur mais en fait
le truc est marrant c'est que ce film
est produit par pathé moi c'est vrai
qu'au départ les gens en fait les gens
ont commencé à parler de mon nom de
famille quand j'ai commencé à devenir
connus parce que quand je faisais des
castings et où que je m'appelle sait
d'où ça changeait pas grand chose j'ai
passé les essais puis j'ai vraiment
passé des essais ils n'ont pas du tout
prise comme ça d'un coup
au contraire ils ont vraiment hésité
puis comme en plus il fallait apprendre
à lancer pour le film je me souviens
j'ai commencé à faire une chorégraphie
de michael jackson devant les
producteurs et tout pour qu'ils me
prennent
le film fait un bide mêlant sa carrière
at il des publicités des courts métrages
et de plus en plus de films français en
2008 elle est la tête d'affiché de la
belle personne de christophe honoré son
premier grand rôle
j'ai déchiré je les lui cette lettre à
23 ans ce film fait d'elle une icône du
cinéma d'auteur
quand j'entrais dans un monde rêvé d'un
coup jacques cédait un peu au cinéma que
j'avais envie de faire ca carrière
s'accélère et se mondialise elle est
choisie pour un petit rôle dans
inglourious basterds de quentin
tarantino colonel ss hans landa à votre
avis les rumeurs qui circulent dans le
village au sujet de votre famille sont
tout à fait fondées
une présence une aptitude à toutes les
métamorphoses qui lui permettent
d'alterner film d'auteur et blockbuster
américain avec woody allen ou ridley
scott
c'est la vérité
je
one canada les dix mois combien de temps
crochet mais le rôle qui fait exploser
sa carrière c'est bien sûr celui d'emma
dont la vida d'elle très bien quand pour
la tournée c'est l'intensité de son jeu
la révèle au grand public un
mécontentement savez combien attendu
prend pour une conne c'était assez dur
c'était assez violent on cherchait on
cherche et on tournait ont tourné des
heures et des heures
donc c'était des pleurs des cris des
décès s'était comme ça c'était
incessants avec ses longues scènes de
violence et de sexe
le tournage est une épreuve c'était pas
facile parce qu'on avait parce qu'il
tournait minimum et trois caméras que
vous m'avez trois caméras braquées sur
nous que il ya eu on était comme ça très
dans un huis clos qu'il y avait je passe
les détails mais que c'était s'était
fait dans des conditions n'étaient pas
c'est pas les conditions plus
confortables
y'avait pas de respect en gros de notre
plein d'autres m'ont dit tu es donc ça
c'était difficile
lors de la sortie du film les
accusations de l'oea font polémique et
le réalisateur abdellatif kechiche lui
répond en pointant du doigt ses origines
familiales privilégiées cela n'empêche
pas le succès du film qui dépassent le
million d'entrées en à peine dix ans léa
seydoux est devenue l'une des actrices
françaises les plus cotés du cinéma
mondial
une carrière qui balaie tous les
soupçons de piston ou de favoritisme
selon son ancien prof
ce que je sais ce qui est sûr c'est que
quand on est à chier on est à chier
donc on peut faire un film mais si on
est à chier on en fait pas d'eux est en
tout cas pas trois il ya 1 à 30
donc à un moment donné on va arrêter de
parler de sites où on va parler de léa
seydoux
a paris il y a quelques mois elle a
encore pris une autre dimension
aux côtés de daniel craig c'est elle la
dernière james bond girl dans spectre un
milliard de dollars de recettes dans le
monde
léa seydoux devient tulle actrice
bankable aux yeux d'hollywood en france
à new york ou à shanghai
la française assure à l'américaine la
promotion du blockbuster évidemment que
john rose c'est un rêve pour une actrice
est difficile de refuser femmes à
chercher c'est exceptionnel envolée la
timidité les complexes de l'adolescence
les hommes c'est désormais jouer de ses
atouts pour faire avancer sa carrière
ces dernières années impossible de la
louper elle est partout
tantôt jeune fille sage tantôt
sex-symbol quand elle n'est pas en
tournage
léa seydoux est une habituée des studios
photos aujourd'hui elle prend la pose
pour un grand magazine français
sensuelle professionnels mais aussi un
peu ironique c'est réussi on trouvera un
peu la bouche
comme ça ah oui mais peu abruti
tiens le vide faire le vide autre le
soir génial super j'adore
il n'empêche ces airs de femme fatale
ont fait d'elle une icône sur papier
glacé est une égérie pour les plus
grandes marques du luxe qui se
l'arrachent
c'est bon c'est leur est bon c'est pas
important tout ça les photos c'est c'est
quelque chose de sa boîte léger ça doit
être un amusement et moi pour moi ce qui
est important c'est jouer c'est
important faire des films c'est
important mais le reste non c'est pas
très important
malgré cette vie dans la lumière
léa garde un visage de l inconnu de tous
bien loin de son image de jeune fille de
bonne famille à 5000 km de paris
c'est une petite île à quelques
encablures de dakar la capitale du
sénégal
gorée 1200 habitants dont la mère de léa
seydoux vallée riche comme hergé est
tombée amoureuse de cet endroit en 1969
bonjour depuis elle vite ici six mois
par an et la regarde le tout petit l'oea
a donc passé ici une partie de son
enfance et revient régulièrement pour
voir sa mère et se ressourcer pour la
première fois elle a laissé une caméra
l'accompagné ici certaines personnes la
connaissent depuis qu'elle est bébé
comme son ancienne nourrice avec toi je
te tuer chez partout c'est vrai mais tu
vas trouver s'est passé à la maison
verte
le défi c'est elle qui m'a apporté dans
le dos et ma fille ma fille chérie
ces dernières années joséphine suit sa
carrière à distance depuis le sénégal
c'est comme temps s'était contenté d
attendre ta maman voilà ma fille l'avait
fallu petite fille les a passés ici
presque toutes ses vacances scolaires
avec sa mère et ses frères et soeurs
environ trois mois par an jusqu'à son
adolescence
c'est donc une enfant du pays qui parle
même quelques mots de wolof la langue
locale la culture
sénégalaise c'est quelque chose qui me
nourrit énormément qui m'inspire et qui
qui a défini aussi qui j'étais et je
pense que je suis qui je suis aussi
parce que j'ai passé du temps ici le
fait d'être comme sa plongée dans une
culture qui n'ont pas la sienne de
s'adapter c'est quelque chose aussi qui
m'a construite pendant ses séjours à
gorée la petite léa même fréquenté la
seule école de ville dans la classe de
cet instituteur monsieur faille
elle faisait le sel de voilà les volets
abattage vous me l'avait confié à six
derrière ses pupitres des souvenirs pour
toute une vie
ici quand on pose une question quand le
maître ou la maîtresse poser une
question les enfants donc en france on
lève le doigt
et ici on fait comme ça fait toujours ça
monsieur à gorée l'oea ne s'étale pas
sur son succès en quête de rapports
sincère avec les habitants à dieu dans
les films français et américain ok voilà
le cameroun voici peut-être oui ça va
vraiment nous ne nous qui veut bien
m'accueillir
là
quant à m
la race abonnés
c'est pourquoi et toi tu perds pas le
tard comme été oui moi je voulais être
boulangère ouais bon manger des bonbons
depuis toujours
valérie la mère de léa seydoux est une
originale en décalage avec le reste de
la riche famille schlumberger elle trace
sa route sans se soucier des conventions
bon ce sera plus joli quand ce sera
quand j'aurai une semaine de plus pour
finir désargentés elle gagne sa vie au
sénégal grâce à ses chambres d'hôtes
qu'elle loue aux touristes donc ça c'est
mon bureau avec ma petite choupinette
qui est là aussi un petit paris match et
anti là que vous suivez ici je reviens
très souvent paris mais je suis quand
même à paris pour l'instant je vais
beaucoup plus mal vivre ici mais je suis
quand même tu trouves pas beaucoup de
temps par beaucoup comme moi oui parce
qu'avec un projet pareil effectivement
vallée riche comme hergé a toujours été
insaisissable pour ses enfants et pour
les as
au sénégal elle a surtout décidé de se
consacrer aux plus démunis
à chaque fois qu'elle vient ici les
accompagne sa mère dans ses différents
projets humanitaires à dakar direction
le local de l'association qu'elle a
créée pour aider des familles en
difficulté léa et sa mère viennent
participer à une distribution de
vêtements rapporté de france par valérie
schlumbergera ma mère de la m j'étais
petit est le mettez une pièce dans la
main et elle me disait
je me disais aussi bien gâté déjà comme
elie mignonne et ravissante
dans cette entreprise solidaire les
sénégalaises viennent d'apprendre la
broderie pour en faire leur métier elles
reçoivent une paye
grâce à la vente de leur confection sur
place et dans une boutique à paris
à dakar les à tient à se rendre dans un
autre lieu fort en émotion dans laquelle
sa mère s'investit depuis huit ans avec
mon bébé
la maison rose est un centre
d'hébergement pour des enfants et des
mères en détresse n'est de viol ou
d'inceste
ces enfants sont bien souvent rejetés
par leur mère cette association tente de
les rapprocher
ça fait très longtemps calé dans la dans
la maison dans la neige rosie très
longtemps savez combien de temps qu'elle
à la maison rose elle ça fait presque un
an et d'éviter elle a quand même très
touchant de voir ses enfants qui sont
nés dans des conditions dramatiques et
comiques recueilli 6 et on leur donne un
espoir
tu habites où tu habites ou moi je
l'avais tag aurait pu revenir chez toi
ouais ouais on veut venir à chaque
visite les add-on un peu de son temps et
de son affection sur sa formidable que
des gens fassent un sex-toy bien mais
c'est très attention quand on est ici
c'est très ému une manière de renouer
avec son enfance à gorée très loin de sa
vie d'aujourd'hui
retour sur la croisette
au lendemain de la présentation du film
de xavier dolan
le festival de cannes bat son plein pour
la jeune actrice ce matin toute l'équipe
du film est attendu pour la conférence
de presse passage obligé des films en
compétition elle ça changerait gorée là
ça change
c'est vrai que quand je lâche parfois
c'est comme si je me déposait un peu
moins d'amour je suis
je suis à l'actrice
dans 48 heures le film juste la fin du
monde remportera le grand prix du
festival
la récompense la plus prestigieuse après
la palme d'or avec le plus beau casting
du festival aux côtés de léa seydoux
nathalie baye vincent cassel marion
cotillard emmené par le canadien xavier
dolan réalisateur le plus côté du moment
un sacre de plus pour une jeune femme à
qui décidément rien ne résiste
oh